chase why he ought to be Raja lives
change organizations guy [ __ ] the
organization is also might change the
world
so think about the last time you sat in
front of your computer on a Sunday
afternoon blank screen you're supposed
to look for that dream job the one
you've almost convinced yourself doesn't
exist or you made a resolution to run a
marathon but 26 consecutive miles sounds
really daunting so you don't even walk
out the door and go for a job or think
about the last time you got your heart
broken and you weren't sure you couldn't
imagine how you were going to recover
and find love again I'm not trying to
depress you but I'm trying to get you to
think about these personal challenges
that can seem so overwhelming that it's
almost impossible to start and I think
it's true in our personal lives and I
think it's true in how we engage with
the world so now try to think about
fixing inner city education in America
when it seems so broken or this downward
spiral of partisan politics in the US
that seems sort of predestined I could
go on but I won't but in my own life and
in the lives of so many people around me
I see how we stand in the face of
seemingly insurmountable challenges
where the outcome seems out of our
control and it's almost like the bigger
the problem the bigger the excuse not to
solve it so it's what really scares me
is this idea of this predestination
thinking these foregone conclusions
where we convince ourselves that we
can't have an impact
and so over the next 15 minutes I'm
going to talk to you about one way that
we can avoid these foregone conclusions
and we can find a path forward so
imagine you're standing at the foot of
Everest foot of the Himalayas and you've
decided you can't summit Everest so
you're not even going to try to get up
the first peak that's the way I think
about it and the best way I know how to
explain this challenge is through a
problem that's very dear to my heart so
it is 8 a.m. on a monday morning in 2009
and i take off onto the streets of
hyderabad india where I lived for about
three years and I'm on my scooter I love
my scooter and I'm dipping and weaving
through traffic and I pull up to a
traffic light and I am surrounded by
motorcycles and auto rickshaws and
diesel trucks and passenger cars and
maybe a camel if I'm lucky on a good day
and as I sit there the conservationists
in me is disgusted I think about my
lungs I think about global warming I'm
asking myself why can't people stop
buying so many damn cars the human in me
the economist in me is thinking how cool
people are moving forward we have enough
income to buy a car and they have
somewhere to go this is progress
and there it is a attention what I
believe is one of the biggest tensions
of our global generation people are
coming out of poverty at a time when
suddenly we care about the environment
when we're aware of resource scarcity
and the rules have changed but I
fundamentally believe that people
shouldn't be punished for bad timing so
the 1.5 billion people in the world that
lack modern electricity deserve the same
energy infrastructure that we have here
one point for economic development on
the other end of the spectrum 1.3
billion Chinese people 1.1 billion
Indians consuming like Americans it's an
unsustainable outcome so I'm this talk
is not about convincing you that climate
science is accurate so I'm gonna ask you
to make two assumptions with me one
climate change exists too we should do
something about it so if you can come
along with me on that then here we stand
economic development and climate change
are slamming against each other and it
seems like a zero-sum game one step
forward for economic prosperity one step
backward for climate change and it seems
intractable and just so stuck un
negotiations on climate change of
stagnated China's polluting more than
the u.s. we see charts like this as the
world prospers the climate goes downhill
and when faced with with this kind of
challenge it's pretty easy to to feel
like there's nothing we can do it's like
watching this slow-motion train wreck
and since we can't do everything right
now to fix
it we do nothing so I'm going to take
you back to that traffic jam so I'm
sitting there I'm generally feeling
pretty upbeat the vibrancy of life
around me I find it all pretty amusing
but there's this this question in the
back of my mind what's the point at the
time I was making clean energy
investments that were trying to reach
the 400 million Indians that don't have
access to energy I was trying to chip
away at this big problem investment by
investment customer by customer it felt
really slow what's the point what if I'm
90 years old and gray and I'm looking
back on my life and nothing's changed
that traffic jam is probably gonna be
worse they're probably still going to be
hundreds of millions of people without
modern electricity why don't I do
something where success is more clear
those questions terrify me that fatalism
and so that got me thinking about how we
motivate ourselves in the face of
monumental challenges where the outcomes
seem fixed and we feel small
so I'm trying to convince you today and
maybe I'm also trying to convince myself
that small does not equal powerless and
that just because you can't do
everything to fix a problem doesn't mean
you can't do something so you're
standing at the foot of Everest at the
foot of the Himalayas and you've decided
you can't summit Everest but you can
climb that next peak and it might be
worth climbing in its own right for its
own sake and it might give you a new
vantage point on Everest and a new path
forward so if my Everest is walking this
narrow Ridge with economic prosperity on
one side and climate change on the other
I'm going to tell you about one peak
that i'm currently climbing you know
what this is it's a diesel generator it
is expensive dirty polluting and it is
the only way that most people in the
developing world have access to
electricity it's my arch-nemesis if the
bane of my existence so you know you see
these in on the streets you see them
across rural areas for pumping water
five million across India just for
pumping water but it's not just poor
farmers it's how business runs
manufacturing telecom mining all running
off of diesel gensets it's the only way
to keep the lights on and for me the
diesel generator is this acute symptom
of this macro challenge it's what drives
the economy
but it's also more polluting than your
typical coal-fired power plant across
the world so here's the catch we pay ten
to twelve cents a kilowatt hour for our
electricity here in the US that diesel
genset I talked to Suraj a manufacturer
in textile manufacturer in Nairobi
recently he pays 35 cents a kilowatt
hour for power three times what you pay
it doesn't make sense so the diesel
genset is one peak and people are
starting to climb up it we're starting
to see progress and it through extending
the grid it's through alternative energy
a number of different people climbing so
you have government in the last 10 years
200 million people have come out have
gotten connected to the grid in South
Asia reducing the demand for diesel
you've got big business involved so that
everyone loves to talk about the mobile
phone revolution across Africa and South
Asia they're mostly run on diesel
gensets those telecom towers they're
starting to offset their diesel with
solar not because not for PR but because
it's economically rational to do so for
the first time you've entrepreneurs
going places where government and big
business won't go Huss power systems
they manage biomass power plants in
rural Bihar one of the poorest states in
India they're serving about 200,000
people with biomass power at a third of
the price of diesel and right now I'm
working with a group on a waste energy
solution that will serve manufacturers
in Kenya likes to rush and replace their
diesel power so we'll eradicate the
diesel genset revolutionize this climate
change economic development paradox we
have
probably not but it is one peak that we
can climb and we should climb because it
makes sense because there's a better way
and because it's fulfilling in its own
right these for me and maybe it will
help us chip away at this huge
intractable seemingly apocalyptic
problem and make it feel a little bit
less apocalyptic so what does this mean
for you maybe development and climate
change